are you Jed King yes where's Jordan this
is your place then
my dad's it's beautiful we're gonna have
more than one date how do you know I
know you sang about God in your songs I
sing about things that I'm passionate
about like rose you know sometimes I
think about letting it go
is it I can live right if I did say
they'd only be because I had something
to say marry me
I had a dream that what you saw notes on
a page
I'm Betty no Julie have you heard of
Shelby Bale
she's your new opener the first time I
heard your music I thought this is it
this guy really gets it
they'll be Bale to the tour we booked a
lot more shows and they got more money
do you need more money or fans
that moment you felt wanted it's a good
feeling isn't it I'm just trying to help
you
good you're not here what is that
supposed to mean
something is wrong Rose I don't know if
you would have heard his real look I
can't sing that song shel it's her song
no it's your song
I want a man who believes and something
bigger knowledge